[Musik]
mein name ist patrick rohr seit einer
woche bin ich als fotograf und
journalist unterwegs in japan
ich hoffe genug stoff zu bekommen sie
ein buch begonnen habe ich meine reise
von einer woche in tokio
die letzten tage war ich im kleinen
bergdorf ein opfer im westen des landes
jetzt bin ich unterwegs nach onagawa im
nordosten
[Musik]
dass ich genau in diese stadt will hat
an grund 2011 hat der zunahme von argo
war komplett zerstört
davor war onagawa ein lebendiges
fischerstädtchen gewesen
10.000 menschen hatten ja gelebt
nichts blieb verschont dasselbe mehr
dass die menschen hier so viel gibt nahm
ihnen alles
827 menschen kamen hier ums leben
die stadt hat sich seither nicht erholt
der este häuser viele leute zogen weg
und kamen nie mehr zurück heute leben
hier ein drittel weniger leute als vor
dem tsunami
früher war lager war ein beliebtes
touristenziel
jetzt gibt es im zentrum keine hotels
mehr
ein reisebegleiter dennis kinzig und ich
übernachten in einer containersiedlung
am nächsten morgen sehe ich wie weit der
wiederaufbau schon fortgeschritten ist
der erste eindruck den ich bei unserer
ankunft gestern hat er täuscht onagawa
entsteht nicht unten am meer nahe
sondern vor allem an den hängen rund um
sagte zentrum
zum teil wurden in den letzten jahren
ganze hügel neu aufgeschüttet damit die
wohnhäuser in zukunft vor dem wasser
sicher sind
auch das neue zentrum wurde erhöht um
acht meter wohnhäuser gibt es hier keine
mehr nur noch leiden und restaurants der
bürgermeister sagt das neue zentrum von
der nagra sondern begegnungsort werden
sie hat sie haben nach dem tsunami
beschlossen bürgermeister von la cava zu
werden üblicherweise fängt man in der
japanischen gesellschaft erst mit 60 an
verantwortungen für viele sachen zu
übernehmen
ich glaube dass meine generation die
verantwortung für die ersten schritte
der wiederauferstehung dieser stadt
übernehmen soll
in japan gibt es viele regeln die
einschränken wenn wir nach der
zerstörung hier einen neuen ort frei
gestalten könnten sehe ich das als große
chance
ich habe gehört dass sollen mittel
jungen leute nicht da zurückziehen was
können sie dazu sagen einheimische die
geblieben sind haben neue geschäftsideen
und junge leute kommen nun von außen her
und starten hier in onagawa ein neues
business wie zum beispiel der junge herr
mit seinen gitarren shop dort drüben da
bringt uns in den getan laden von noeske
caccia der kommt dass tokio und ist erst
vor kurzem nach unna gezogen loske
caccia produziert mit seinem team ganz
besondere gitarren elektro getan für
rock aber auch traditionelle musik die
einzelnen teile werden nicht wie üblich
vernagelt sonnen verleimt was war für
sie der grund hierher nach onagawa zu
kommen
dieses geschäft aufzumachen und hier
gitarren zu produzieren
als ich das erste mal hierherkamen
spürte ich dass dieser ort eine starke
energie ausstrahlt die leute versuchten
bereits neue geschäftsideen umzusetzen
die fisch firmen zum beispiel möchten
neu nach übersee verkaufen
so dachte ich diese stadt ist ein
wunderbarer ort um ein gutes produkt
herzustellen
[Musik]
dieser rief ist ein gitarren intro der
schweizer band gotthard
was für eine überraschung der
bürgermeister ist auch ein rocker als
gitarrist in einer heavy metal band
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich bin sehr beeindruckt sie sind ein
richtiger rocker an gott komme ich nicht
heran
und woher kennen sie die band aus der
schweiz seien auch nach japan gekommen
und das hat er damals gehört das
vereinskonzept und heute spielt er sie
selbst
[Musik]
sechs jahre nach dem tsunami leben immer
noch menschen in container siedlungen
kalt eng und fast ohne privatsphäre
und die neuen siedlungen im oberen teil
der stadt sind zwar schön und modern
aber eben auch anonym
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen um halb fünf treffe
ich am hafen von sascha hammer einem
vorort von onagawa
er ist 47 jahre alt und kommt von hier
die fischzucht der familie führten
dritter generation
wir sind unterwegs zur work is
fischfarmen nach dem tsunami waren sie
komplett zerstört
vier tanks hatte insgesamt in jedem
schwimmen 30.000 silbe lachse eine tonne
futter kleine brocken aus gemüse mehl
und fußknochen
burkes bruders hilft bei der rabatt auf
dem meer
es muss schnell gehen sobald die sonne
da ist tauchen die fischer schnell in
tiefe gewässer
[Musik]
jetzt wo ihr alles so friedlich ist kann
ich mir gar nicht vorstellen was für
eine zerstörerische kraft das meer vor
sechs jahren entwickeln konnte wie habt
ihr es hier in dieser bucht aus gesehen
am elften märz 2011 am morgen war dass
mir noch ganz ruhig als der tsunami kam
begann auch der schneefall
das war sehr schlimm auch sind steht
wurde zerstört
das ist ein neues schiff
dort ist also ein vater coming tsunami
ums leben
da draußen
war mit seinem vater im haus sie
flüchteten zusammen
aber es reicht nicht mehr es habe zwar
einen alarm gegeben sagt nobuaki
ungefähr 30 minuten vor dem tsunami
doch sie hatten davor schon so viele
fehlalarme erlebt dass er auch diesmal
nichts schlimmes vermuteten tanz
reagierten war es für den vater zu spät
[Musik]
nowacki hat beim tsunami fast alles
verloren immerhin haben sich inzwischen
die fisch preise nieder erholt nach der
atomkatastrophe von fukushima waren sie
einige jahre im keller
das dorf wurde auf einem flash
aufgeschütteten hügel weit hinter dem
meer wieder aufgebaut
viele menschen sind trotzdem weggezogen
ihm gefalle es sagt nobuaki besiedlung
sei kompakt rasers alte dorf und die
nachbarn hätten heute mehr kontakt
untereinander als früher
unten siehst du den alten damm
jetzt wurde ein meter beton obendrauf
gelegt das meer ist ihr leben leben vom
fisch das gleiche mehr hat tod und
verderben über ihr dorf gebracht ihnen
den vater genommen
was haben sie heute es gibt mir ein
gutes leben und ertrag wenn ich mich
anstrengen trotz der angst schätzt sich
das meer immer noch sehr das alte dorf
lag direkt hinter dem damm
auch die familie lebten aber mehr
dies kann aber genau hier stand das haus
es war sein land in diesem bereich
direkt am meer
obwohl es im moment sehr mühsam ist
bleibe ich vor allem an zwei töchtern
zurück
ich bin seit 30 jahren fischer und kann
mir schlecht vorstellen woanders zu
leben mit einem anderen beruf die natur
sie gibt und sie nimmt nowacki hat
gelernt mit ihr zu leben
[Musik]
zu den wenigen gebäuden in onagawa die
nach dem tsunami nach standen gehört das
krankenhaus es steht 16 meter über dem
meer als man als vor 20 jahren gebaut
hatte schaute man darauf dass es hoch
genug liegt um bei einem tsunami
geschützt zu sein
[Musik]
das wasser stieg dann allerdings auf 18
meter
das ganze erdgeschoss wurde überflutet
alle daten des krankenhauses alle
patienten dossiers sie wurden vernichtet
so hoch steht das wasser damals das
krankenhaus wurde mit spendengeldern aus
der schweiz wieder aufgebaut in den
obersten zwei stockwerken hat man neu
dass autos und pflegeheim untergebracht
ich darf beim menschen fotografieren
ich möchte mir das allerdings mit seinem
einsatz als hilfs pflege abverdienen
bitte ziehen sie für ihren einsatz die
angestellten uniform an die wir hier
täglich tragen
wir würden uns freuen wenn sie uns heute
mit helfen könnten
da frag ich mich ebenfalls darauf vielen
dank vor meinem einsatz auf der autos
player abteilung treffe
krankenhausdirektor mit zur seite er war
im arbeiten als der tsunami kam
ich möchte von doktor seite wissen ob
damals hier auch menschen zu schaden
kamen
ja es wurden menschen aus dem
erdgeschoss weggespült unsere
angestellten im ersten stock kamen knapp
mit dem leben davon
das wasser drang ein schwan und
schwemmte sie an die decke hoch
sie hat nur noch knapp 30 zentimeter
luft über sich dann ließ das wasser
glücklicherweise nach sofort nach dem
tsunami war schwierig zu begreifen dass
das was sich vor unseren augen abspielte
die realität war und nicht etwa ein
alptraum
ich glaube dass sie in der oberen
abteilung bereits einige vom personal
kennengelernt haben alle angestellten
die an jenem tag im spital gearbeitet
hatten wussten zuerst nicht was mit
ihren häusern und ihren familien
geschehen war
trotz dieser bedrückenden ungewissheit
sind sie pflichtbewusst im spital
geblieben und haben sich unermüdlich und
die patienten gekümmert weil viele
menschen nach der tat das so für
weggezogen sind braucht es plötzlich
nicht mehr ein so großes krankenhaus das
schaffte platz für das neue
altenpflegeheim hallo alle miteinander
wie schon am morgen angekündigt haben
wir heute gesucht guten tag und dann
schlage ich vor dass wir nun unseren
übungen machen
auch die füße bewegen
[Musik]
und der platz für das pflegeheim war
nötig in onagawa gibt es wie in ganz
japan immer mehr alte leute und die
werden immer älter
das ist auf der einen seite schön öfter
an einem problem weil gleichzeitig die
geburtenrate sinkt darum sind auch die
renten alles andere als gesichert dass
die menschen in japan immer älter werden
hat verschiedene gründe
sie leben und essen sehr gesund und das
gesundheitssystem ist eines der besten
auf der ganzen welt
[Musik]
bis vor nicht allzu langer zeit lebten
die eltern bis zum tod bei ihm kindern
das ist heute auch in japan dem seltener
der fall
und weil es immer weniger junge gibt
gibt es auch immer weniger
pflegepersonal für die alten menschen
[Musik]
lösen lassen würde sich dieses problem
nur wenn es mehr zuwanderung aus dem
ausland gäbe doch da ist japan sehr
streng
die hürden für ausländer sind hoch auch
für pflegepersonal nicht einmal zwei
prozent der bevölkerung in japan sind
ausländer
[Musik]
oberschwester aber macht sich sorgen
wer sich in zukunft noch um die augen
kommen spüren sie das spüren sie dass es
immer mehr alte leute gibt ja
tendenziell leben die jungen nicht mehr
bei den eltern
alte menschen werden allein gelassen
oft wohnt eine alte person alleine in
einem haus dazu kommt ein anderer
gesellschaftlicher trend immer mehr
junge japanerinnen und japaner
beschließen als single durchs leben zu
gehen die x wenige menschen heiraten
werde eine lösung dass jede familie
wieder mehr kinder hätte ich glaube dass
es mehr braucht
wenn die heute verteilt lebenden
familien wieder wie früher zueinander
finden und miteinander leben würden dann
würde wohl eine bessere gesellschaft
entstehen denke ich es ist wichtig dass
die verbindung wieder gestärkt wird
zwischen einzelnen leuten und den
familie auch lokal im dorf das ist der
richtige weg
[Musik]
die herausforderungen für japan sind
groß wissen 30 jahren soll es im land
ein drittel weniger menschen geben
und die meisten sind dann im
pensionsalter ich habe keine ahnung wie
sich ein kollaps des landes verhindern
ließe ich habe im altenpflegeheim viel
gelernt und viel gesehen
zum abschluss fotografiere ich die 100
jährige immer so habe sie hat im leben
schon viel gesehen es waren intensive
tag im norden
zwei wochen bin ich nun schon in japan
in dieser zeit hat mir dennis mein
reisebegleiter viele türen geöffnet und
er hat mir viel erzählt über die
japanische kultur
jetzt muss er zurück in die schweiz
seine firma braucht
[Musik]
am bahnhof tokio nehmen wir abschied
voneinander von jetzt dann muss ich es
alleine schaffen
mit hilfe von lokalen übersetzerin
[Musik]
doch bevor ich weite reise möchte ich
mir etwas nicht entgehen lassen
ich habe die möglichkeit bei der
reinigung eines schimpansen zu helfen
einem der japanischen
hochgeschwindigkeitszüge das klingt
einfacher als es ist wenn man weiß
welche hohen ansprüche man in japan an
jede tätigkeit stellt der suppe wieso
der reinigungsfirma erklärt nur das
nötigste
am wichtigsten sei der putzlappen sagte
der müsse richtig gefaltet sein wenn man
ihn nicht richtig halte gar nichts
dann lerne ich wie man einen zug und die
passagiere empfängt
ja sie haben richtig gehört in japan
begrüßt das reinigungspersonal den zug
und die passagiere
und schon geht es los drei minuten haben
die passagiere zeitung auszusteigen
dann kommt das kommando zum putzen
wie von geisterhand drehen sich die
stühle in fahrtrichtung und auch das
passiert wie von geisterhand
[Musik]
naja
sieben minuten haben ja um den wagen zu
reinigen
zum glück sind wir zurzeit die kollegin
ist schon 5 1 weiter das ist jetzt
stelle ich das system mit dem lappen das
ergibt schon sinn
wir haben es geschafft vor allem meine
kollegin hat es geschafft sie musste
sechs monate in der ausbildung bevor sie
zum ersten mal alleine einen wagen
reinigen durfte ich verstehe warum
dazu vermutlich ab pro jahr hat ein
schinken sind zusammengerechnet nicht
mehr aus einer minute verspätung
[Musik]
von tokio reisig weiter richtung fuji
mit 3000 meter der höchste berg japans
und das wahrzeichen des landes
ich habe nach den fuß yoshida
mittlerweile habe ich mich an den
linksverkehr gewöhnt doch auf dem weg
zum fuß habe ich plötzlich das gefühl
ich hatte eine panne
[Musik]
es dauert etwas bis ich begreife dass
die rillen im asphalt eine milliarde
erzeugen
[Musik]
es sei ein volksliebling fuji steht am
straßenrand
[Musik]
der grund warum ich nach fukushima
gekommen bin ist gar nicht der fuji ich
bin wegen der oder nudeln hier eine
japanische spezialität
in fukushima soll es um die 60 dollar
ausgeben
manchmal ist ein restaurant auch das
wohnzimmer einer familie
ich möchte herausfinden was das
erfolgsrezept der oder nudeln lässt
dann erfahre ich dass es jemanden gebe
der möglicherweise mit mir reden würde
diese person arbeit im supermarkt es ist
rihanna kam ein 18-jähriger schüler an
fünf abenden in der woche arbeitet er
will geld verdienen um sich bald sein
und großen traum verwirklichen zu können
er will ein eigenes restaurant eröffnen
[Musik]
das sind es also die oder nudeln warum
braucht es drei jahre um zu lernen wie
man sie herstellt was macht es so
schwierig neben der nudeln geht es auch
um die beilagen und den richtigen
geschmack der suppe
das alles zu lernen ist gar nicht so
einfach und kann sehr wohl drei jahre
dauern
liga ist der gründer des nudel clubs an
seiner schule
ich denke morgen gerne vorbeikommen sagt
er aber zuerst soll ich doch erst noch
den fuji genießen
[Musik]
das ist tricks schule die hebamme gauck
a high school
heute sind sie minute club zu viert am
kochen die beiden jungen frauen eier und
ruhiger sind wie ich zum ersten mal hier
[Musik]
super sound tricks sind schon seit
jahren dabei
sie zeigen uns wie man macht
[Musik]
als erstes nimmt man reines wasser vom
coaching ein spezielles mail und fünf
gramm salz daraus macht man einen teig
[Musik]
richtige oder nudeln sind nicht der hand
sondern auch fuß gemacht
patocka marke hiergegen hat kann nicht
wirklich drauf stehen eine neue
erfahrung für mich ich brauche muskeln
von denen ich nicht einmal gewusst habe
dass ich sie habe
so verdient habe ich mir eine mahlzeit
noch nie den einzigen offiziellen ruder
und club in japan gibt es seit zehn
jahren
dicke war damals ein achtjähriger junge
doch die faszination für die oder nudeln
ließen seite nie mehr los noch heute
entdeckt er jedes mal wenn rudel macht
neue tricks um die härte und textur der
nudeln zu beeinflussen
sogar beim schneiden kommt geschäfte
genauigkeit an nokias leidenschaft seine
freude an nudeln machen berührt mich zu
wasser bereitet inzwischen die suppe vor
er schüttete ziemlich viel soja sauce
rein mehr als sonst bei einer suppe und
dazu mir so passte aus der region auch
davon recht viel
und während die suppe köchelt zeigt mir
rica zwei zeitschriften
es gibt dann rudern heft ja das bist du
wer macht das du ich bin wirklich
beeindruckt
woher kommt deine leidenschaft
vorgeschmack der geht mir direkt ins
herz
nein noch nicht
du weißt du dass sie glänzen wenn sie
fertig sind vergangen hatte da es gibt
wirklich viele kleine geheimnisse beim
rudern machen
[Musik]
bis zum schluss ist krieg ja völlig
konzentriert mit kaltem wasser möchte
den nudeln ab
[Musik]
meine ersten selbst gemachte nudeln für
den geschmack kommen jetzt noch bonito
thunfisch blocken und chiliflocken dazu
die sind sehr scharf
die nudeln sind ein genuss und das
monster von darf ja muss das habe ich
schon früher gelernt
ich freue mich bei den weg das lässt
raum zu gehen in fuzhou china
[Musik]
die tage in der lage war beschäftigen
mich immer noch
ich bin froh konnte ich bei den nudeln
machen ein wenig abschalten
im zug kann ich endlich all meine
gedanken aufschreiben ich bekomme immer
mehr ein bild von japan
von georgina reisig weiter in die alte
kaiserstadt kyoto
[Musik]
der bahnhof von kyoto sieht ein bisschen
aus wie eine raumstation
bei der eröffnung vor 20 jahren wurde er
in japan sehr kontrovers diskutiert die
einen fanden er sei ein schandfleck für
die historische stadt die anderen waren
begeistert über seinen futuristischen
look
[Musik]
kyoto ist eine sehr lebendige moderne
stadt
[Musik]
als einzige große stadt in japan hat
carter aber auch noch einen historischen
kern motto wurde im zweiten weltkrieg
von den bombardements verschont
es ist kirschblüten zeit in japan die
wichtigste zeit im jahr man feiert im
frühling denn anfang allen lebens in
dieser zeit den kyoto ein hotel zu
finden ist fast unmöglich wie ich
feststellen muss aber ich habe glück im
kapsel otto nein es gibt es noch freie
nun ja kapseln hier ist der lift für
männer und frauen getrennt
rot ist für frauen
seinen namen eines und ein stunden
direkt das hotel weil man für eine nacht
nicht mehr braucht als neun stunden eine
für die toilette 7 zum schlafen eine zum
aufstehen
alles ist hier reduziert aufs
wesentliche für das gepäck gibt es nur
wenig platz dafür gibt es einen pyjama
und pantoffel wenn ich jünger wäre würde
ich auf meiner reise wahrscheinlich
möglichst oft in einem solchen hotel
übernachten
jetzt bin ich froh ist das vorläufig mal
eine nacht so stelle ich es mir im
weltall vor
die nacht ist kurz aber dafür habe ich
gut geschlafen
ich bin froh denn schon um haut sex
fängt man tagen zusammen mit
übersetzerin teuer bin ich auf dem weg
ins tor von joker motto eine der wenigen
kampfkunst rennen in japan
joko kam otto ist 62 jahre alt sie ist
eine kita seien sei eine aikido lehrerin
und trägt den sechsten dan sexton
schwarzen gürtel
das bedeutet dass sie ziemlich erfahren
ist und es ist auch ziemlich stark klar
wer hier der meister ist jetzt gehst du
erst mal seine sitz meditation
währenddessen sitzt du so die augen sie
nicht geschlossen
[Musik]
meine erste lektion in kampfkunst ist
zuerst einmal die kunst gegen mein
inneres zu kämpfen
40 minuten im lotussitz mich nicht
bewegen
geradeaus schauen ein und ausatmen
gedanken kommen und wieder gehen lassen
eine spannende erfahrung
[Musik]
richtig zu atmen und zentriert zu sein
sei es eher wichtig das finde ich sehr
schön aber jetzt habe ich frauen den
kampf in den beinen
ich muss mir meine fotos wieder mal ab
verdienen
ich finde das gut denn einerseits war
ich so eine beziehung auf zu den
menschen die ich ablegte und
andererseits werde ich so teil des
geschehens
weil ich noch nie gemacht habe und darum
während der lektion frauen im weg stehen
würde
helf ich heute wenigstens beim putzen
ist die harmonie ist die energie ist
also der weg die energie zu
harmonisieren zu harmonisieren mit der
natur und jedem einzelnen individuum und
ding das auf der welt existiert
schülerinnen und schüler kommen aus der
ganzen welt
sie bewegen sich wie in einem ballett
allen scheint jede bewegung klar zu sein
niemand redet an bord
du arbeitest ohne worte folgen sie dir
einfach wie könnte ich die natur und all
die schönen dinge erklären
sie sind einfach schön du musst sie
sehen und fühlen wahrnehmen
das system konnte das selbe es gibt
nichts zu erklären für mich ich werfe
sie uns sie müssen das für
[Musik]
der weg des aikido ist zu akzeptieren
ohne sich daran zu klammern
ohne widerstand er gibt es noch nicht
wenn du aggressiv bist und ich werde
auch wenn du wütend ist brauche ich aber
nicht wütend auf dich zu sein
ich akzeptiere es und denke es um bis in
zwei personen
ich kann dich und mich aber auch aus der
perspektive einer dritten person
beobachten wie wir nicht uns in einem
film sehen würde wenn du also wütend
fest brauche ich das nicht persönlich zu
nehmen
genau das geschieht auch hinter sitz
meditation yoga sagt eike damit von
erleben fühlen nicht verstehen
eigentlich wären der fotografie das
heißt ja nicht grundlos ein bild sagt
mehr als tausend worte würde aikido mein
leben verändern
ich weiß nicht was möchtest du denn
verändern würde konzentrierter
geduldiger genau darum geht es beim
aikido ist also viel mehr aus sport es
ist eine persönlichkeit schulung und man
lernt mit körperlichem training auf
situationen angemessen zu reagieren mit
klarheit respekt und eigener stärke ohne
aggression genau so erlebe ich eine
faszinierende frau
toyota hat eine sehr lebendige und
vielfältige gastroszene es fällt mir
schwer zu entscheiden was ich auch die
ersten sollen
[Musik]
ich besuche an isa k wörtlich heißt das
sagt laden zum sitzen was mir gefällt
ist dass man aus vielen verschiedenen
kleinen gerichten auswählen kann
ich habe viel erlebt die letzten zwei
wochen
in onagawa fing der bürgermeister
plötzlich an zu rocken
dort fotografierte auch die 100 jährige
frau habe und fische nowacki der beim
tsunami alles verloren hat und ich
lernte joker kennen die mich sehr
beeindruckt hat
[Musik]
in der nächsten und letzten folge unter
werfe ich mich anstrenge legten in einem
cent
ja
dann fliege ich nach rock ihn aber eine
insel im süden
dort leben die ältesten menschen der
welt sie empfangen mich sehr herzlich
und ganz unten im süden after insel
ishigaki lärm echten bootsbau tumor her
kennen
er zeigt mir sein tropisches paradies
[Musik]